if I ask you what's your favourite piece
of souls related artwork something will
probably come to mind maybe it tells a
story or maybe it took a lot of
technical skill to create maybe it's a
picture of siegmeyer as banana it
doesn't matter my point is that art can
make you laugh it can make you imagine
and wonder
so let's marvel at some art and hear
from the talented artists who created
Dark Souls had already been out a year I
think I know for me it was a game that
consumed my life this is Carson of
Carson Drouet if you don't know Carson
chances are you at least know his work
his other cute characters that appear on
my Dark Souls prepare to cry videos and
he was the first artist I ever worked
with I went to work and all I could
think about was Dark Souls I would sit
there and rather than actually do work
which is terrible to say i sat there
looking up concept artwork and stuff
just being completely enamored with with
this property this love of the game
inspired creation and it wasn't long
until Carson had this small gallery of
uncolored Dark Souls characters as well
as this growing fanbase urging him to
color them all in and make more Carson
allowed me to use some of his work in
the thumbnails of my law videos and
honestly these simple cute characters
are probably a big part of why prepare
to cry even became popular I talked
about commissioning and what it means to
me with another artist John Devlin I get
like a small sense of what the artist
must feel which is like I helped create
something or I did create something and
it what didn't exist before and now
hundreds of people can enjoy that you
know is that how you feel when you
create a piece yeah that's exactly it
like I mean there's people I've gone
through like I think 50 to 60 emails
with just for one picture like we'll
just go back and forth and back and
forth and I don't mind I'd all like give
me and its day a picture like so I'm
pretty fast at what I do so I'm able to
try things together really quickly and
yeah look I'm doing that constantly so
well I know exactly what you mean this
is John who did
gorgeous commissioned for this videos
thumbnail actually I love his work and
you can probably see why it's really
unique isn't it every piece has this
bold angular and compact look to it it's
like the center of the piece is tightly
controlled but the edges are chaotic and
erratic in the way that they spiral out
it's a really distinct style I think it
is very very important to have a
distinct style because you'll always be
saw after and if like 20 other people
are not even 20 like hundreds and
thousands of other people can do your
style well Daniela you're not as unique
and people won't come here once if you
can offer people to do a job for them
and they can't find anyone else to do
why yeah I think that's a good thing to
have if you're making eleven as an
illustrator so it works out for me
anyway Oh John soules related work spans
Dark Souls and blood-borne most of it
started during inktober an event where
artists challenged themselves to create
an ink drawing everyday for 31 days this
is the picture he did on the first day
it's the channeler from Dark Souls 1 one
of John's favorite designs he's written
this message along with it that says
tempted to make all of my images for the
31 days Dark Souls related and over
sixty eight Souls related pieces later
I'd say that those 31 days went pretty
well and when the space was a few days
of finishing in Cobra it sold every
single one of the pictures and from
selling them all people who didn't get
one we're commissioning me to do their
own pictures and it just kept going and
going and it's still going even now so I
would say for sure like when it when
that Dark Souls community came about
like that was probably the most support
I've seen that everyone's been very
friendly and they also like exploring
lore and that kind of stuff so I first
became aware of solo back in 2013 when
she entered the Dark Souls to shield
design contest wyvern wall features a
wyvern scales woven onto a great shield
unwavering gaze has this chilling eye
covered with a bloodied hand suggesting
that it must have been some poor guys
last sight
and soullow explains the last shield
here which I found particularly
interesting the one I put in the most
effort was divine intervention it was
like it was neato the furtive pygmy Gwen
and the witch of izalith so I
represented all for them like Gwen was
symbolized with the dark sign and the
chains as kind of warming a Sun kind of
feeling Nita were the skeleton hands I
was grasping at the bonfire in the
middle and the witch of izalith had the
little tree roots at the bottom um and
so I try to like combine all four which
is like the basis of Dark Souls 1 like
into that shield so looking at Souls
work you really see the effort and
thought put into every stroke she paints
digitally so while you're watching one
of her twitch art streams you'll see
these pieces gain depth and detail on
top of what was already looking pretty
good and if you're really lucky you
might even get to see her draw something
like a cheeky little neato under
nashandra stress for twitch that's like
an interesting phenomenon because it's
interacting with not only the Cheddar's
but directly with the streamer and you
can take on feedback and integrate it
just to entertain them I just drew neato
under there except out it was a really
funny idea that you guys suggested so I
wanted to put that in there because it
looked like he could fit under her skirt
while we were talking she mentioned how
some of these pieces can take months if
inspiration falters or if you're unsure
how to finish a lot of these artists I
talked to mention having this problem
happened to them actually bricking one
of your hard drives doesn't help either
that can slow you down I accidentally
kicked over one of my hard drives I
don't know why put it on the floor but
it was on the floor I kicked it over and
they're like pretty much like all my dad
was lost so I was really bummed out and
I'm just like you know what that's fine
I'll just start over and really Dark
Souls kind of reminds me a bit about
that where you put in all this effort it
doesn't really matter if you die you
just have to start over sometimes you
just have to pick up the pieces and
you can't you can't like dwell on the
things that you've lost you just have to
keep pushing forward one of the things
that's really fascinating to me is
learning what it was that propelled an
artist to fame some like Carson or John
they find an audience through many
pieces over time and others like our
next artist Judson spend months working
on their magnum opus so I you know I'll
put it a PNG put it up on reddit and
went to sleep and then the next morning
I woke up and it had been uploaded like
a thousand times and kotaku had already
picked it up this like unfinished
artwork and run a story about it and the
editor of edge magazine which is like
the best gaming publication in the UK
had gotten in touch with me was like hey
can we print this in the next issue of
the magazine I was just like it's not
done it's not done but that all that
support kicked me in the ass and got me
I'm working on it you know outside I
finished it Judson is the artist behind
Laudate solace it's this hugely
ambitious vertical illustration of
Lordran
that captures this staggering amount of
detail most of it being completely to
scale scrolling down through it you
start to comprehend the beauty and
complexity of dark souls's world design
and of course the amount of effort that
this piece must have taken I was working
constantly when I was I have a 9 to 5
job so I would get home from work I'd
make a sandwich and I just sit down and
work until I went to sleep for a month
like it absorbed all of my time and at
some point I decided I would put a like
second color texture on since fortress
and it looked good enough that I then
had to do it the entire map which like
added another 40 hours of work on the
project interestingly Judson says that
it was the linear world of Dark Souls 2
that made him want to capture the
complex into woven world of Dark Souls 1
at a glance this piece instantly clicks
with that world map of Dark Souls 1 that
we all intuitively know from playing the
game so much art can change your
perspective
you might play Dark Souls 1 now with
this newfound appreciation for the world
and the relationships between areas now
that you've seen Judson's piece and
that's a pretty special thing that he's
captured here but this next body of art
we're going to talk about is a part of a
project that goes beyond changing
perspectives it could also affect your
experience with the game it's a web app
called blood book so blood book is an
application you play alongside with Dark
Souls 2
it doesn't affect ourselves to in any
way but what it does is it gives you a
goal and a method of play that's
different from just invading the goal is
to do a sequence of PvP invasions with
with objectives and the loose tie that
holds it all together is these tiny
snippets of story and character
development your goal with blood book
simply put is to complete 20 PvP
contracts and acquire as much gold as
you can by the end of it all let's run
through a hypothetical contract together
first I have to retrieve it it's buried
directly in front of the flame
salamander guarding this tunnel I grab
it the contract tells me that I need to
invade and assassinate a royal last
scene in bright stone Cove it's also
required that I hide my face with a mask
or a helm we don't want them to see me
and the contract also gives me a list of
optional objectives that I can complete
to acquire more gold like landing a
backstab or killing the opponent with
fire bombs things like that naturally I
put on the Bell helmet and I invade that
helmet actually ends up saving me from
an arrow in this clip which I thought
was pretty amazing apparently my target
is sniping me from above and he
ultimately kills me because I can't get
back up there
and I fail the contract as punishment my
next contract has to be completed with
the lowest camera sensitivity and this
is just one of many punishments and one
of many adventures you can have but most
importantly every page of this book has
a fascinating little fragment of story
to go along with it and a piece of art
to help your imagination along a little
bit it's like having a quest log for PvP
and it wouldn't be half as good without
the artistry that ty has picked up in
his life we have this community that is
in part fueled by our artists ties blood
book is one example and there are
hundreds more that I'll never have the
time to mention in one video a lot of us
when we love something we simply enjoy
it but in my experience and in many
others when you love something one of
the best things you can do is create and
share something with the world saying
all this reminds me a lot of a talk
ahead with cannon breed who is a really
talented pixel artist who when Dark
Souls 2 was getting hyped up he started
creating art based on the slivers of
information he'd seen I decided it would
be a cool idea that when there was only
a few trailers I try and recreate
characters out of what I saw are the
undead jailer okay and I just thought I
want to try and recreate him in like
pixel form because I was the language I
spoke I guess and I wanted to see if I
could create him before anyone really
saw what he looked like completely so I
just made that and I was like one of the
first few kind of souls related pieces I
made Alex says that the souls community
is full of people who aggressively seek
out creators and their creations and
it's true we're all forced together by
the difficulty of this game and by our
love for it cannon breeds pixel art has
represented a lot of the most complex
designs in Dark Souls in this simplified
manner that cannon breed says breeds
even more create
so it seems like that's the purpose and
the idea of making these d-max is to
kind of imagine what would happen if the
same person with the same idea made the
same game but with a restrictor medium
20 years earlier 30 years earlier
another guy who's done Sol's D makes is
a guy called the silikov who a lot of
you are probably familiar with yes so
recently I did a scholar of the first
sin D make that was pretty fun
that was like a PlayStation 1 version of
scholar of the first sin and everyone's
like this is in Kingsfield silikov has a
great library of Dark Souls animations
and you should go check them out my
favorites are when I'm gravelord in' and
Rogue Warrior looks like it's trying to
go beyond dev basilica's jokes and his
cartoons aren't the surface level jokes
they're not the ones that are like Oh
Dark Souls is so hard ha ha ha
type of jokes that you can expect from
more of the popular channels he noticed
pretty early on that making even the
most niche jokes would get a really good
response from the community at the time
when I made it Dark Souls wasn't even
relevant you know even my sort of well
in animation circles it was like well if
you're doing that no one's gonna watch
it because you know if you're an
animator and you want to live off that
or become famous whatever you've got a
make stuff that's sort of relevant or
you know you gotta catch it while it's
hot type thing and so was at that point
you know I sort of decided you know I
think you actually encouraged me a lot
to say like hey you should just make
Dark Souls cartoons I was like ok let's
go with it
whatever yeah because it was like an
itch that no one had really been
occupying at the time and I think
everyone was finding that whether it was
through art on tumblr or videos about
the law or with you it was animation you
know no one was doing it so they just
loved it and they lapped it up and yeah
this niche has continued to grow with
your help one of the best success
stories in my
has been the work done by a really
talented team over at lordran and beyond
a group of four artists who are really
talented who banded together to create
an ongoing series of web comics set
within the souls universes their manager
a guy called Zach talk to me briefly
over email about the project it's really
exciting he talks about how these comics
explore interactions between characters
who never even meet in game allowing us
to witness these new situations
inspired by character traits and
circumstance check out the links in the
description afterwards and read through
the story of Sieglinde as she searches
for her father laugh at juror as he
protects the beasts of the hunt from
Gascoigne
or imagine a story where Eileen watches
in dismay as her friend Gascoigne
descends into madness
this is a hugely ambitious project that
I support a hundred percent and you can
too you can support them on patreon and
you'll get a bunch of perks along with
the knowledge that you're supporting a
project and artists who are creating
something that everyone can enjoy
that's something I've noticed from being
on patreon I only have 800 patrons but
they're making it so I can create
content for hundreds of thousands of
people so you know even one person even
you contributing just a little bit can
make such a difference and all of this
is really made possible by you the
viewer whether you support these artists
financially or whether you just support
them by saying hey I really like your
stuff keep it up you're the fuel for
their fire and there's so much
opportunity for us to come together and
support and consume and enjoy being part
of one of the best communities on the
internet there are so many people I wish
I could fit into this video I want to
tell you about bandy grass who created
this gorgeous little gif I commissioned
that I now see across all the corners of
the internet it pops up everywhere I
want to mention Ian who I can always
rely upon for a speedy high-quality
Commission there's Kelly Duvall who I
commissioned for the unique Demon Souls
thumbnails back
in the day and there's animators like
Aaron or rice pyro
who put out some of the funniest Dark
Souls animations on the internet but
finally the art that means the most to
me personally is pretty simple
it's this little VAR t avatar and the
hexyl style banner that I commissioned
way back when from a hugely talented
lady named ETL so I hope that you go on
from this video to click every artist I
can possibly name in the description and
I hope you join me in celebrating all of
this work that we're really lucky to set
eyes upon I've been talking a long time
so thanks guys and also keep an eye on
the Facebook Dark Souls page the artist
named dreaded cone or ty who was
featured earlier in this video he hinted
that he'll be showcasing a bunch of Dark
Souls artists work over there in the
coming weeks and months so let's get
some hype going for that and that's it
cheers guys thanks for watching also if
you want to support the videos I make
like this one which required me to
organize seven interviews and go through
hours of audio and edit together this
narrative and if you want more videos
like this one then you can click through
here to learn more and the support is by
no means necessary it's just appreciated
so thank you for watching